hey everyone welcome back to reboot
GameSpot's opinion editorial show I'm
Mike McCarty and I'm Jake Decker and
here we are on the final second-to-last
episode of season 2 of reboot jqn
explain what we're gonna be doing for
our final episode of 2017 yes so next
week is a short week it's Thanksgiving
those you in the u.s. so we work Monday
to wednesday and I mean if there's a
Friday off and unfortunately that is not
enough time to do a full episode of
reboot so instead what we were thinking
is we were going to kind of go over some
of our favorite games not necessarily
GameSpot's favorite games that you're
definitely not that it's just some games
that either we think flew under the
radar or games that we think deserve a
special shout out and hopefully fans of
the show will enjoy that and maybe kind
of get a look at some of the games that
we enjoy it and maybe games you can pick
up over your break to check out yeah cuz
Jake you and I probably have a few games
that game spot as a whole won't have in
their top 10 or whatever and again yeah
we're gonna do lobby up Awards on our
live show more like best soundtrack best
writing and then games by itself will
have its Game of the Year awards as
normal but like you said this will be
our personal one it'll probably be like
it'll be a good way almost like a Gift
Guide like if you didn't play this small
game that might come up a little small
like indie game that might have come out
in July you should play this right away
maybe like and then of course everybody
who's comes to watch it recommend us
that's our favorite thing when people
recommend games we played a few rooms
Reeb it was because a reboot that I
played heat signature' reached semi
recently that's like the best gift
people can give is recommendation for a
good game that we might have missed so
that'll be a good opportunity for Jake
and I to kind of pimp ones that we think
might have gotten overlooked or need
more one get more respect as you're
heading into the holiday season to buy
games or taking time with family and
friends to play games while you have
hopefully have time off whether you're
in the US or outside of it because this
is pretty much our last actual episode
of season two of reboot is longer than
season 1 we're not done yet
as we get into the holiday season things
get super busy so we'll probably pick it
up again in January yeah but uh but last
week on our last big episode of the year
and the second season of reboot was
about called the new world war 2 its
campaign specifically again I want to
start off by saying this because most of
the comments were saying yet you gave
the game a 9 I didn't give
me and Miguel concepción who reviewed it
for GameSpot are different people lo and
behold we have very different tastes we
have very different opinions and a lot
of people are saying well
Miguel's review represents GameSpot no
it doesn't it's a review it's a
subjective thing from one person anybody
who says yeah when you go into review
you kind of have to cut from an
objective mindset like not have anything
inherently against the series or the
developer or the people who made it I
agree with that there shouldn't be any
conflicts of interests but as soon as
you start playing game and have an
opinion it's subjective it's an opinion
it's me and you probably despite the
fact that we both kind of think World
War 2 s campaign was lackluster maybe
you liked a little more maybe you like
certain parts maybe someone like that
train crash that you and I hated but
it's you're yes we're representing
GameSpot in terms of behavior and art
decorum and in our tone but when we
actually go to have an opinion
GameSpot's not this autocratic thing
that says Miguel thinks this so
everybody has to agree with him or Mike
said this on reboot so Miguel your
review has to reflect that and we have
to average out of the buddy's opinion
that's not how it works it's just you
picked the best person for the review in
this case Miguel concepción knows call
of duty really well he had a very
well-written review you should go read
that if you want a different opinion of
the whole game I just didn't like the
campaign the fact that I still have to
explain that to people who are actually
not just trolling and thinking that it's
it's smart to say oh well they're
representing GameSpot again in behavior
and decorum and tone yeah we are
especially the public and on camera but
know what our opinions we're not
GameSpot doesn't have an opinion
GameSpot's individual editors and
producers have their own opinions which
collectively becomes GameSpot's voice
and most people get that I apologize if
this is redundant and it's long-winded
but it gets me pretty heated talking
about it and I'm sure even right now
people are commenting right now arguing
that and that's fine you have an opinion
that's different than mine that's half
the point yeah I mean just reading
Miguel's review of Call of Duty I'm sure
I don't agree with a lot of what he says
and what he enjoyed but reading through
his review I can see why he he back
about a nine yeah he backed up why he
thought that game should get a nine and
I stand by his review and that I believe
that he felt that game deserved a nine
but when I play it personally like if I
was asked to score quality which I never
a few games I that's not my job
but if that was me I would probably give
it something lower but if you're joining
us there's one of our Q&A episodes if
you're new to the show every other week
is Q&A episode we go back to YouTube
comments Twitter questions and address
them because that's half the point of
reboot Jake I would let you start off
with his first youtube question the
first one is from blood angel' 13 this
person says here's my question
why is Call of Duty World War 2 in the
European campaign wouldn't it be much
more compelling if the same was set in
the Pacific example Okinawa was one of
the worst battles in the Pacific
campaign or when the British and even
warriors fought the Japanese Imperial
Army in the jungles of Malaysia I think
right off the bat it's a bit tougher to
tell a Pacific a a world war 2 story in
the Pacific because that's less of a
battle against good and evil like Nazis
verse allies yeah like I mean it's in
humanities history Nazis are like almost
I mean not nowadays in America but most
of the time Nazis are considered just
plain evil and it's like you said it's
easy to tell a story in there Japan did
some messed-up stuff during World War 2
the rape of China is called the rape of
China for a reason but there when you
look back and you see like Imperial
Japan in the 1940s it does become a
little there their motivations are
different than Nazi I think when we
think world war 2 we think Nazis and it
does become a little bit you know it's
also like the fighting itself was very
guerilla warfare and Japan's part
especially the farther in the American
they're all the forces like United
States Marines Army Garrison Navy got to
across the island hopping the more
desperate and kind of just like no
surrender a lot of Japanese forces
became so those become more common
yeah I mean like Medal of Honor Rising
Sun I thought was fun that was more that
was less actual trying to be authentic
that was more like the Medal of Honor
them farther they in the guy you were
like a segregated kind of in the world
of war yeah World War II yeah between
the Russian front going into Germany and
Pacific Theater yeah like Guadalcanal if
I'm you Jima was a yeah yeah but yeah we
can kind of I think we might get into it
soon but I would have loved to see
something different than this Omaha
Beach landing that we've seen so many
times before and then this battle of the
Bulge we've seen so many times for these
are all historic catastrophic events and
maybe there's a new generation of people
who have not played medal of honor and
allied assault or call of duty the
original or called duty to or called
three three or four others in arms
tactical games or seen banner brothers
or seen Saving Private Ryan or a bunch
of World War two movies that someone
mentions in the next question but if
they made it good-looking but they
didn't do anything new and I think if
they made such a big deal about going
back to their roots and going back to
boots on the ground combat which they
said over and over like I think they
should have like half the point is they
didn't earn it they just told this
retreaded cliche World War two story
that even if you're new to like World
War two in games you've probably been
exposed to this stuff before and it
doesn't have to be super I'm not saying
has to be realistic it's never gonna be
a realistic war game and if there is
like I don't know if I'm gonna want to
play it but it's just a matter of do
something new it's that's half my
arguments I've seen all this before and
either parts that they did try to do
something they just tried to make the
set pieces crazy the belltower the train
crash it's like what 20 seconds longer
maybe yeah something like that
yes after so I have to playing infinite
warfare which isn't a game I didn't
particularly love I enjoyed but one
thing I did really liked about that game
is how it all it was all real time like
there were no like two months later
loading screen here's another set piece
it was completed mission on the ground
getting your ship fly up to your frigate
or whatever and then pick another
mission getting your ship and go back
down like I thought that was really cool
it took place in one span of time one
continuous span of time and I was really
hoping to command
call duty yeah exactly I was hoping that
in Call of Duty World War two they'd do
something like that but on the world
like during World War two like maybe you
land on Omaha Beach and you're it's like
one continuous push as you move move up
rather than just like take Omaha Beach
in 20 minutes and then we get a little
cutscene and then a loading screen and
then it cuts to the map where it shows
the arrow is pushing for it and next
thing you know you're here like that
that it feels like a greatest hits of
world war two battles and that was cool
for a long time but now it's I was
hoping they'd do something a little bit
more interesting maybe like on the
eastern front as the Soviets get pushed
out of Stalingrad and then try to take
it back like I think that would have
been a much cooler game especially if it
just stuck there the entire time yeah it
would have been a better sense of time
and place I think if it's something like
that I think it really well thank you
bloody angel 13 for your YouTube
question here's another one this is
really well written out I told him we'd
be featuring this on the show
Timmy 51m I only used the first
paragraph because again it's long but
it's worth reading if you have chances
toward the top of comments as of this
recording but I took the first paragraph
and he said there are quite a few films
that I really enjoy set during World War
two Kelly's heroes we're Eagles their
escape to victory the Dirty Dozen the
Guns of Navarone these are not real
stories and if I understand your
argument correctly then none of these
have earned the right either because
they cannot show you why they couldn't
take place in any other place or time
they all could in a film based on an
actual event Steve McQueen didn't earn
the right to go jumping a motorbike over
fences and the Great Escape that never
actually happened but they filmed it
anyway and it's great so it is so is it
also not okay to get a lover over the
top and imagine if even if you are
during World War two it's hell yeah it's
completely okay to get over the top and
imagine it in World War two if you do it
right look at Wolfenstein the new order
that was set during World War Two in
alternate history your BJ blaskowitz
your that's bombastic that is just like
embellish that's amplified as hell
saboteur like this noir resistance spy
thriller game which you should play if
you haven't played it how many years ago
is that 2011 2010 now I think 2010
overlooked game you should track check
that out if you want like historical
fiction that uses a cool it uses it
setting its World War 2 setting to
propel the story and to tell a cool
story like it could have been told like
if it was like resistance like if you
want to get more moderate it could be
told like from Iran or like like Iraq or
something in modern but they use the
world war 2 setting to propel it forward
in terms of as far as it's like a period
piece but World War 2 at answer your
questions to me 51 many of those movies
you saw you'd mentioned except for
Kelly's heroes I've seen all those I'd
loved the Dirty Dozen I loved the Guns
of Navarone you're right some of those
stories could be told elsewhere and the
Great Escape could have been told about
something else but I still think they
use their setting to amplify the story
right it's they use that time period to
comment on what was going on and I don't
think what works who did I think it was
generic cliches with lieutenant Turner
and sergeant Pearson you know of course
the compassionate lieutenant versus the
you know the by the books mission
oriented sergeant it got it got annoying
the people we were playing as and then
of course Sussman and your main friend
there such clichés like Texas farm boy
and you know Jewish New Yorker that
we've seen some of you're a long way
from home farm boy yeah where I'm from
we had to stand up for ourselves that's
a good I think it just needed to do
something new again this kind of ties
back to last question but what if you
entered what if you entered Normandy on
a glider those are the things that used
to transport weapons and supplies
instead of in a parachute or off Pointe
du Hoc from Cosby to or on Omaha Utah
Beach landings or I mean I know there's
a generation who hasn't seen those as
much as you and I have some many people
watching this but even if this year is
if World War two called World War two as
your first exposure to a world war two
in an interactive medium
you're better off playing call of duty -
you're better off playing middle of on
or allied assault if you want to go back
in your father we're just watching those
movies that - last one over this one as
well
humanity or it's at it's humanity on
Twitter as a constant friend of reboot
sending questions a lot in our live show
the lobby and GameSpot in general I said
this is a loaded question for Twitter
but how would they earn it I understand
your criticisms from the video but it
sounded like yes they depicted a
realistic World War 2 setting but they
didn't make it real enough to go back to
kinda what I was talking about was
saboteur and Wolfenstein that doesn't
necessarily have to be real enough but
sledgehammer has said over and over
Michael Condrey and Glen Schofield have
said they're trying to be authentic you
know boots on the ground and you can
punch me if you want for saying I hate
saying that but they they very much just
like we're trying to go with the
campaign itself they've said zombies are
supposed to be over-the-top multiplayer
is supposed to be fun and representative
of who you want to be like there's a lot
of people of color and multiplayer that
you can be because they're not going for
historical authenticity and in the
campaign they kind of touch on the the
white soldiers relationship or at least
like astonishment that there's a black
man in the army which was I wasn't there
but I assume there's really realistic
cuz there were not many people of color
in combat in World War two there were
definitely same World War one like the
Harlem Hellfighters but it wasn't
prevalent and I thought that almost
touched on some cool stuff to talk about
they didn't I think it didn't it didn't
it wasn't totally consistent like they
like half-assed the authenticity with
called view World War two but then all
of a sudden there was this forty second
train crash or this like bell tower
think escape where you feel like a
secret agent I felt like James Bond when
I feel like they were trying to make
trying to make me feel like a regular
soldier and I feel like I just split
down the middle yeah you mentioned it
before but I often you can't do often
tissa T 50% like you either are
authentic or you're not authentic and
this tried to do authenticity 50% but
then when I play it like sure you don't
have regenerating health
you've got Zeus min or whoever throwing
you health packs but it's like does this
add anything no not really like it's
just like a little little gimmick that
they added to change it up but
yeah I mean it they they set
expectations for a game that was
supposed to be you know very
historically accurate of the time and
then you play it in it like I said it
just feels like a greatest hits of
different different battles that are
just blown out of proportion and like
yeah I don't know I def I lost interest
in that campaign yeah it's pretty much
it if you want to go read more in depth
about the whole game go read Miguel
Concepcion's review it's very good he
liked the game a lot more than I did but
again we touch them at the beginning the
episode as for that thanks I just also
want to say thanks so much for everybody
who stuck with us there's season 1 & 2
of reboot if you haven't it's almost
been a year yeah Resident Evil 7
finishes what Silent Hill started was
episode 1 we shot that in the basement
of our friend's hotel if you know if
you're wondering where we shot those
creepy scenes and if this doesn't sound
familiar go watch it cuz I liked that
episode it's a good way to kick it off
but yeah thanks so much for everybody
who constantly wrote in to the show on
YouTube or Twitter or GameSpot I thank
you everybody who's always giving us
comments criticism and helping us make
the show better because we couldn't have
done it without you and we're gonna keep
involving you obviously and like Jake
said next week over the u.s.
Thanksgiving weekend it'll be fun like
it'll just be pretty much you and me
just you know yeah oh man thing about
our same thing now just talking about
favorite games of the year maybe we'll
do like a let's play during it yeah who
knows people have been asking on these
Q&A episodes to play the game we talked
about that could be a cool a cool thing
that might be more interesting to watch
then I was throwing up b-roll which
you've been seeing this episode but yeah
again everybody thank you so much for
watching and before we start the next
season we'll do one more episode where
we talk about our personal favorite
games we'll see you then thank you
[Music]